Barena
Welcome, do you still have your ego?
I'm a former psychic detective, so let's
compete tan
I wonder if you'd like to show me a little more of your
wonderful power It's on the face of the customer
So it's
power  It's fine to have that,
it's a 0 pair, it's an evil spirit
Do you know where the boys, abilities, and central abilities open up and come out of?
But the
greatest feature of humans is their abundance of emotions.Since they have
emotions, they reflect them and they have the opportunity to
fight.Dentist-kun can't use his psychic powers anymore.
What are the many
emotions saying?
Don't you struggle with people who are in pain?
We can make a difference stronger than we are right now
Just by changing the way we see the world a little